I definitely grew up being like gotta
get good grades I've got to get a good
job I've got it you don't get married at
a certain point I know if I'm not given
like sort of obstacles I don't really I
get kind of leave like I don't need to
base my sense of self on what strangers
opinions in me I like once your
technique gets to a certain level the
only thing that separates you from
others is your quirks or even flaws I
think it's a really good tool to just to
learn something from everyone you work
with
she's an actress film director and
producer and carries dual
American and Israeli citizenship her
performance in Black Swan received
widespread critical acclaim and won her
her first Academy Award for Best Actress
she was cast as Padme Amidala in the
Star Wars prequel trilogy
she's Natalie Portman and here's my take
on her top ten rules for success my
personal favorite is number eight I make
sure to stick around all the way to the
end for some bonus footage it's very
hard to separate the you know the things
that other people want for you the
values that society tells you you're
supposed to go after and the things that
are really meaningful for you you know I
definitely grew up being like got to get
good grades I've got to get a good job
I've got it you don't get married at a
certain point I've got it you know you
feel like there's these things that
you're supposed to do and that you're
you have to do and then it's an amazing
shift I'm sure many of you get have
gotten there you know or will get there
if you haven't but it's an amazing thing
when one day you're just like oh this is
what is important for me and I don't
care what they say I don't care why you
know why other people think I'm doing it
or not doing it the rest is sort of ego
you know and yeah can you name that
moment when that happened um I don't
know I think it really started happening
when I was doing
arts that required like a real sort of
immersion for me you know working on
things like boys ghosts or V for
Vendetta The Other Boleyn Girl I did so
much sort of like I I got so into the
characters in the stories and all the
background research and and really like
living in it and it made the outcome
like not important when it did well when
it didn't do well when I got positive
feedback when it didn't it was like all
that stuff sort of faded away because I
had this experience and the experience
was like oh you can't take away from me
the fact that I spent you know two
months going to the Prado everyday and
like living with like Koya and El Greco
and Velazquez paintings like that was an
experience forever that I will never
remember no never never forget and and
and the fact that you know four people
saw the movie of course like you know
obviously when you care about something
you want people to engage with it and
it's important but it wasn't devastating
because I had something that was with me
forever you know and and so it changed
the way I chose projects because it
wasn't about like you know it's the
worst when people are like oh this is
going to be really popular this is going
to be like an Oscar movie and you're
like badsign Bad's and in beds I'm like
why do why is this meaningful for me at
this point in my life that I want to
live this experience people told me that
Black Swan was an artistic risk a scary
challenge to try to perforate portray a
professional ballet dancer but it didn't
feel like courage or daring that drew me
to it
I was so oblivious to my own limits that
I did things I was woefully unprepared
to do and so the very inexperienced that
in college had made me feel insecure and
made me want to play by other's rules
now was making
we actually take risks I didn't even
realize were risks when Darren asked me
if I could do ballet I told him that I
was basically a ballerina which by the
way I wholeheartedly believed when it
quickly became clear in preparing for
the film that I was maybe 15 years away
from being a ballerina
it made me work a million times harder
and of course the magic of cinema and
body doubles helped the final effect but
the point is if I had known my own
limitations I never would have taken the
risk and the risk led to one of my
greatest artistic and personal
experiences and that I not only felt
completely free I also met my husband
during filming and what compels you to
get involved in the project I know it's
kind of a hard question because it's
probably so many different things but
when you think about projects that you
get involved with what is sort of some
of the key elements well I think you
know it can be really anything that gets
you interested I just always I just want
to make sure I'm gonna be challenged the
whole time because I know if I'm not
given like sort of obstacles I don't
really I get kind of lazy I don't really
engage in the way I want to so if I know
something's going to constantly be
throwing challenges at me not in like I
want to have fun you know that I always
want to enjoy what I'm doing but
something that is going to be that's
part of the fun I think is getting all
the you know the challenges of it do you
read criticism of yourself no I used to
I used to and then I realized and it
wasn't helpful positive or negative mmm
it's just a distraction yeah I can't I
don't look at anything anymore that's
written whether it's like interviews or
I mean it's just it's also just too much
focus on yourself mmm it's like I am far
from the center of the world and I don't
need to like I need to read about other
things there's a lot of really good
things to read about and I know about
myself and if someone makes a mistake
about me I'm just gonna get upset so or
if they say something negative I'm going
to get upset and if they say
nice that's friendly but I also don't
need to care like I don't need to base
my sense of self on what strangers
opinions in me are like it's important
to me that my friends my family you know
think that I'm behaving correctly and
they'll let me know if I'm out of line
and and everyone else's opinions like
you know it's not it's not my business
by the time I got to making Black Swan
the experience was entirely my own I
felt immune to the worst things anyone
could say or write about me and to
whether an audience felt like going to
see my movie or not it was instructive
for me to see that ballet dancers for
ballet dancers once your technique gets
to a certain level the only thing that
separates you from others is your quirks
or even flaws one ballerina was famous
for how she turned slightly off balance
you can never be the best technically
someone will always have a higher jump
or more beautiful line the only thing
you can be the best at is developing
your own self writing I think everyone
probably has a different process but my
sort of experience is that I have an
idea for a story in my head for a very
very long time and little things sort of
glom on to it I don't write any like
notes right heading down and then after
like a couple years it sort of just
comes out and like one spurt like it's
just sort of like mold itself and in my
head and then it just comes out and so
that is what happened with both
occasions and then once I get my first
draft out I send it out to like ten
people I trust which I know a lot of
writers don't do this is not a normal
process a lot of people really tinker
with it a lot but I sort of do my leg
this crazy first draft and then get
people's feedback and then and then
start doing all this very various sort
of detailed work using the feedback and
then it sort of inspires me too because
it gives me and we're kind of
active that I don't have because I think
this stories in my brain so long that
you know you get too close to it amazing
thing about Darren is that I feel like
the yeah there's not the ego that like
that just doesn't there's some people
who just feel like I'm the boss I'm
gonna like make the rules he asked
questions he listened and took ideas
when they were good and when they
weren't good he's like that's not a good
idea and you just wouldn't do it and
that's fine you know that's always what
you're doing as a cast or crew member is
like you know you bring your ideas and
if they're right great and if they're
not not theirs I've definitely worked
with people who are like don't want to
hear anything they're like that's not
your job like just go do what I tell you
to do you know which makes it less
interesting of course and then in words
there's people who like listen too much
and then they water down their own
vision which of course is not a problem
for for Darren but that's the joy also
it that was something I learned when I
was directing to to just like have an
open ear and use people's best
suggestions so you have like a hundred
people who are there for you to help you
create your vision and sometimes they
have a good idea what do you want from a
director I really I love feedback I mean
I think part of my like you know I like
I just I think artistic honesty is the
key and I mean Darren is exactly that
you know I'll tell you when it's not
going well and I'll tell you when it's
going well and you can trust but it's
going well when he says it is because
he'll tell you if it's not and he always
had you know a million different ideas
for every scene was always on top of it
and then at the end would always say do
this one for for yourself the last one
do it for yourself which was just
exactly the key to the character because
it was what Vincent says to you know
Vincent's character says to my character
which is find your own pleasure which is
at the root of being an artist which
Darren handed
find your own pleasure find your own
pleasure because you're trying to so
often as an actor you're pleasing your
director it's like you know the kids at
the pageants at the end when they like
look at their mom right after they
finish during their song sometimes
you're like that as an actor you finish
the scene you're like that was it you
know and and when when they're saying
just do it for yourself it's a whole new
world opens and and Darrin gave that to
me because directors often say like do a
freebie or a free one but just putting
those words articulating it in that
particular way do it yeah I think it's
really I just I think it's a really good
tool to just to learn something from
everyone you work with you know like
every person you work with steal from
them you know yeah I mean stealing I
think stealing from people when you're
acting is really easy because it's
always going to be funneled through you
so no it's it's not plagiarism in any
you know no one will ever know unless
you're really really good at the risk of
sounding like a Miss America [ __ ]
contestant the most fulfilling things
I've experienced have truly been the
human interactions spending time with
women and village banks in Mexico with
finca microfinance organization meeting
young women who were the first and only
in their communities to attend secondary
school in rural Kenya with free the
children a group that build sustainable
schools in developing countries trekking
with gorillas conservationists in Rwanda
it's a cliche because it's true
that helping others ends up helping you
more than anyone getting out of your own
concerns and caring about someone else's
life for a while
reminds you that you are not the center
of the universe and that in the ways we
are generous or not we can change the
course of someone's life even at work
the small feats of kindness crew members
directors fellow actors have shown me
have had the most lasting impact
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because you guys asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do I'd also love to know which of
Natalie Portman's top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you how did it move
you how did the change your mindset
leave it in the comments below and I
will join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon
I think it's always really helpful to
just incorporate anything that's
happening in life into your into your
work obviously in a way that makes sense
but they you I think acknowledging in
and sort of threading in to what you're
doing is is always helpful as we get
older we get more realistic and that
gets and that includes about our own
abilities or lack thereof and that
realism does us no favors people always
talk about diving into things you're
afraid of that never worked for me if
I'm afraid I run away and I would
probably urge my child to do the same
fear protects us in many ways
what has served me as diving into my own
obliviousness being more confident than
I should be which everyone tends to
decry and American kids and those of us
who have been great inflated and ego
inflated well it can be a good thing if
it makes you try things you never might
have tried your inexperience is an asset
and will allow you to think in original
unconventional ways accept your lack of
knowledge and use it as your asset I
know a famous violinist who told me that
he can't compose because he knows too
many pieces so when he starts thinking
of a note an existing piece immediately
comes to mind just starting out one of
your biggest strengths is not knowing
how things are supposed to be you can
compose freely because your mind isn't
cluttered with too many pieces and you
don't take for granted the way things
are the only way you know how to do
things is your own way what's your
ambition now I think to take it back to
enjoying not working
I am i I've been working so much and I
think I've gotten into a sort of yeah
workaholism that is unhealthy so I'm
learning to enjoy my life without having
to be busy all the time